In today's lecture we continue
discussing formation defenses.
While the defenses we've considered
to this point have focused on how the
contract was formed,
we now turn our attention to defenses
that focus as well on what the contracts
say.
We begin by examining the
unconscionability doctrine
which in part inquires into
the fairness of the contracts terms.
As with our other formation
defenses of incapacity mistake,
fraud and undue influence,
you should be able to see that a finding
of unconscionability is consistent with
the goal of policing the
revealed preference inference.
When courts are not confident
that a party's a manifestation
of ascent indicates
that the contract is value enhancing,
the courts are more likely to let
that party void the agreement.
We already introduced the
unconscionability defense
when we earlier discussed
Williams versus Walker Thomas Furniture.
The excerpt assigned for today's lecture
which comes from a 1989 case called
fleet versus us counts consumer council.
Dell's further into how courts apply
the unconscionability doctrine today
in fleet,
the defendant United States consumer
counsel represented that it would be able
to help consumers facing the loss of
their homes through four co closure.
In fact,
the USCC simply charge consumers for
referring them to attorneys when free
referrals were available
to these consumers through
their state bar associations.
The plaintiff fleet was a consumer who
had paid defendant for this service.
Fleet brought this consumer class action
suit against USCC in the instant court,
the Federal District Court for the
Eastern District of Pennsylvania and the
court found that u s CCS
practices were unconscionable.
So did USC sees practice of charging ill
informed consumers for a simple service
that could be freely obtained elsewhere,
violate New Jersey's unfair and deceptive
practices act well the the court held
that it did the court first notes that
unconscionability is hard to define but
states that its purpose is to
establish a broad business ethic.
Among other factors,
the court will consider whether the
price grossly exceeded the price at which
similar services were readily obtained
in similar transactions by light
consumers and whether a professional
seller is seeking the trade of those most
subject texts.
Boyd station in this case,
the court found that USC sees practices
were fraudulent because quote goods sold
have little or no value to the consumer.
For the purposes for which
he was persuaded to buy
them and quote the consumers
who turn to USCC for help.
We're financially troubled and distraught.
The modern unconscionability
doctrine is only about 50 years old,
but has historical antecedents.
In 1750 the court of chancery describe
an unconscientious bargain as one such as
no man in his senses and not
under delusion would make
on the one hand and as no
honest and fair man would
accept on the other.
This quotation is suggestive of what I
earlier described as the upstairs Nian
inversion.
Some bargains are so
substantively unconscionable
that there must have been some
procedural defect in their formation.
One of the parties must have been not
in his senses are under delusion or
somehow tricked a into the contract.
This case and other similar earlier cases.
However,
we're not brought under a single clearly
established doc trinal umbrella until
the latter part of the 20th century.
Crucial in this process was
the publication and enactment
of the UCC section two
three Oh two which permitted courts to
deny enforcement with regard to contracts
for the sale of good,
where a contract is unconscionable.
At the time it was made this language
unconscionable at the time it was made
makes clear that the doctrine
is a formation defense to
be judged at the time of
a contracts formation as opposed to the
impracticability defense that will study
later that often concerns impracticability
or impossibility that arises after
the contract is formed.
While the consideration doctrine
does not inquire into the adequacy of
consideration when courts
decide unconscionability cases,
they demand proof.
Not only that the contract
terms are substantively unfair,
but they also require some procedural
defect in the process through which the
parties arrived at the agreement.
In other words,
although the unconscionability doctrine
focuses on what the contract terms are,
this is substantive unconscionability.
Courts must also consider and fine some
degree of procedural unconscionability,
some defect in the
process of its formation.
The excerpt from fleet
illustrates this point.
The court considered factors other than
the simple disparity between the price
paid and the market value of the services.
The court noted that unconscionability
is more likely to be applicable.
One a professional seller is seeking
to the trade of those most subject
exploitation,
the uneducated,
the inexperienced in people of low incomes
applying this asymmetry to the case
at hand.
The court observed the consumers
who turned to USCC for help.
We're financially troubled and distraught.
Some were unemployed or disabled.
Many were facing the loss of
their homes through foreclosure.
These factors were
indicative of imposition.
They had nothing to do with what the
contract said, that substantive terms,
but it helped explain how
these unfair terms came about.
So let's imagine the following quiz.
A large manufacturer enters into a routine
contract to purchase a large number
of widgets from one of its suppliers.
Also a large company after
signing the contract.
But before accepting delivery,
the manufacturer learns at
several alternative suppliers,
would have provided the same
number of widgets for 30% less.
Can the manufacturer assert
an unconscionability defense
under fleet and get out
of the contract?
No.
Even assuming that the manufacturer
could show the price was unfair.
This hypothetical is missing the
element of procedural unconscionability.
It's missing evidence that there
was a defect in the process.
The contracts in fleet.
We're between a professional
seller exploiting vulnerable,
vulnerable consumers.
The manufacturer in this example is a
large sophisticated company engaged in
routine business transactions.
Standard form contracts presented on
a take it or leave it basis or often
referred to as contracts of adhesion.
California courts have taken the lead in
holding that a contract of adhesion is
always procedurally unconscionable.
The unconscionability question in
California then boils down to whether the
bargain is sufficiently unconscionable
from a substantive standpoint to warrant
non-enforcement not withstanding
California's position.
However, contracts of adhesion
are generally enforceable. Thus,
while the phrase contract of
adhesion has a pejorative overtone,
it's important to keep in mind that most
adhesive contracts will be judicially
enforced.
Merely are to merely arguing that your
clients signed a standardized contract,
a contract of adhesion that was presented
on a take it or leave it basis will
not normally be sufficient to avoid the
finding of an enforceable agreement.
If this were not the case,
internet commerce would be dead because
virtually all internet purchases come
via click it or leave it.
Contract shall offers.
The unconscionability doctrine might
be conceptualized merely as a default.
If a seller cures the procedural defects
in formation and the consumer still
consents to a substantively
one sided contract,
the doctrine at least as a conceptual
matter would allow enforcement.
But to my mind,
a fair reading of the of these
unconscionability cases suggests that
unconscionability is
more of a mandatory rule.
While fine print procedural defects
can be remedy other defects concerning
consumers circumstances and the
party's relative bargaining power,
uh, are virtually impossible
to cure. So that the doctrine,
the doctrine substantive cap on one side,
sidedness represents a mandatory
restriction on freedom of contract.
Let's end with a hypothetical.
A pharmacist in a small town in a
mountain valley typically sells medicine x
over the counter for $5 and has
a good inventory for the winter.
There are no other drug
stores of violence.
No storm closes in the
valley with 30 foot dress.
And now outbreak of illness creates
a demand for this very medicine.
The pharmacist has enough in stock to
supply everyone who's ill but now charges
$25 per bottle on a take
it or leave it basis most.
Take it two days later,
a cal helicopter lands
with enough medicine, uh,
for everyone at $5.
Those who took it demand their
money back should they get it.
And what about the nonlegal
sanctions against the pharmacist?
Well,
there are some statutes prohibiting price
gouging during a weather disruptions
in the marketplace.
These statutes are inconsistent
with one type of, uh,
efficiency theory. If the blizzard
makes medicine more valuable,
it's efficient for a
pharmacist to raise the price,
even if the current
inventory was presumably, uh,
was purchased by the store at
a lower pre blizzard price.
Price Gouging gives the stores better
incentives to stock larger quantities and
make sure that the medicine ends up in
the hands of the highest value in users.
Instead,
the price gouging statutes tend to
randomly distribute the medicine or force
higher value users to waste
efforts racing to the stores.
This is not to say that the
price gouging statutes are wrong.
Sometimes equity, Trump's
efficiency concerns, uh, uh,
in the public consciousness
and in our laws. Well,
let's review today.
We talked about the unconscionability
doctrine and under the unconscionability
doctrine and contract will not be enforced
if it's terms or seriously unfair to
one of the parties. However, such such,
such substantive unfairness is not
usually enough to set aside a contract.
The Complaining Party must
also demonstrate some flaw
in the bargaining process
that allowed the unfair terms to arise.